with so many awesome marvel movies and
television shows on the horizon it can
be hard to keep up with the comic
juggernaut's ever-growing entertainment
roster
fear not we're here to give you a
glimpse of all the upcoming marvel
projects
outside of and beyond the mcu's upcoming
phase four
agents of shield has improved steadily
while seeming to be perpetually beyond
the bubble
it's been in real danger of cancellation
by abc on multiple occasions but has
always received a stay of execution from
corporate parent disney
season 5 ended on a note of relative
finality so it surprised pretty much
everyone when the show was re-upped not
only for a sixth season
but a seventh it was in fact the very
first series to be slaughtered by the
network for 2020.
at san diego comic con in july 2019
marvel tv head jeff loeb
confirmed that the seventh season would
be the last both seasons would be
slightly truncated featuring 13 episodes
as opposed to the standard 22 of
previous seasons
in the interest of forging a lean and
mean narrative season 6 has chosen to
forego
any references to the larger marvel
cinematic universe
up to and including the world changing
events of avengers infinity war and
avengers end game
to focus on telling its own story the
season has focused on the organization's
rebuilding period and the new leadership
as phil coulson was confirmed to have
died shortly after the events of season
five but this rebuilding is disrupted by
the appearance of mysterious
interdimensional hostiles led by a man
who happens to look exactly like coulson
it seems certain that shields writers
already have a pretty good idea of how
it will play out going into next year's
seventh season
but as for the rest of us we'll just
have to wait to find out
the sumc or sony universe of marvel
characters
if you're not into the whole brevity
thing was born of sony pictures deal
with marvel studios which allowed marvel
to integrate spider-man into the mcu
in exchange sony continues to produce
our web heads mcu said solo outings
and also has free reign to develop its
own universe based on ancillary
spider-man characters
this universe's inaugural efforts 2018's
venom
cleaned up at the box office while
satisfying fans of the character
left cold by topher grace's unfortunate
portrayal in sam raimi's spider-man 3.
after that somewhat unexpected success
sony was quick to fast-track another
spidey-related property that had been
gestating since 2017.
that would be morbius based on the
living vampire and frequent spider-man
nemesis
who first appeared in the pages of
marvel comics in 1971
the flick will star jared leto as dr
michael morbius
a brilliant biochemist whose attempts to
cure his own potentially fatal blood
disease with an experimental treatment
involving the blood of vampire bats go
predictably awry transforming him into a
super powered ghoul who must consume
human blood to survive
daniel espinoza directs from a script by
lostin space co-creators
matt sazima and berg sharpless we'll see
if the sumc can establish a dark
hurricane streak
when the movie hits screens on july 31st
2020
while nearly all of the upcoming marvel
projects presented at stcc had either
long been rumored or actually confirmed
there was a single outlier that came as
a complete shock to the crowd
to conclude the panel kevin feige
presented two-time academy award-winning
actor mahershala ali
whose scintillating performance as a
villain cut and mouth was the best part
of the marvel netflix series luke cage
feige then announced that ali would star
in the title role in an mcu incarnation
of blade
and jaws throughout all hage could be
heard hitting the floor as far away as
la
what is that
[Applause]
the first movie adaptation of blade
released in 1998 and starring wesley
snipes as the half human half vampire
hero
is sometimes considered to be the first
modern superhero film the flick spawned
two sequels and for virtually the entire
existence of the mcu
fans have been wondering if the day
walker would ever get his time to shine
in the mcu feige put that speculation to
rest in dramatic fashion
and the involvement of the immensely
talented ali is nothing short of a coup
no further casting or plot details were
announced but there is one bit of bad
news
feige confirmed that blade will not hit
screens until the mcu's phase 5.
call it the great controversy of 2018.
in july of that year the news broke that
james gunn the writer and director of
the beloved guardians of the galaxy
franchise have been let go from the
third installment over a series of old
tweets that had been dug up by
conservative pundits
guardians fans were up in arms but a
silver lining came in august
when it was announced that gun's
completed script would be used the
search was on for a new director
a search that continued right up until
march of 2019 when disney put an end to
the whole kerfuffle by seemingly saying
the hell with it and rehiring gun
the nearly year-long impasse will have
the effect of delaying vol 3 for a bit
as it didn't take gun long after his
canning to find another gig
at rival warner brothers writing and
directing a reimagined suicide squad for
dc
marvel studios has agreed to wait
patiently until guns work on that film
which is slotted for release in the
summer of 2021 is done before putting
volume 3 into production
meaning that we're not likely to see it
hit the big screen until at least 2022
marvel isn't playing koi about king
t'challa's second solo outing
it doesn't have an official title or
release date but black panther 2 has
been officially confirmed by the studio
not exactly a huge surprise as the
original became one of the highest
grossing films of all time
and marvel's first received serious
oscar consideration
winning three for its original score
costume design and production design
not only is the sequel officially
happening but feige revealed to
entertainment weekly that the concept is
already coming together nicely he told
ew
one of the favorite pastimes at marvel
studios is sitting around on a part one
and talking and dreaming about what we
would do in a part two
there have been plenty of those
conversations as we were putting
together the first black panther
we have ideas and a pretty solid
direction on where we want to head with
the second one
writer director ryan coogler is
officially on board and while nothing is
confirmed it's expected that the
principal cast including chadwick
boseman
lupita nyong'o and tanay gurira will
also return
it's even been rumored that michael b
jordan's eric killmonger could return in
some capacity
despite being left in no condition to do
so at the end of black panther in light
of the mega bugs that film made we're
likely to get additional details on this
highly anticipated
sequel sooner rather than later given
the fact that it kicked off a universe
of spider-man characters which will not
so far as we now know
actually features spider-man the success
of sony's venom was a bit of a shock
anchored by tom hardy's completely
bonkers performance the film cleaned up
at the worldwide box office of the tune
of 855 million dollars
making a sequel inevitable of course
having learned a few tricks from marvel
studios sony made sure to go ahead and
set one up in advance with a
post-credits scene featuring woody
harrelson
as cletus cassidy the psychopathic
serial killer who would go on to bond
with carnage the venom symbiote's
offspring
venom 2 was at one time assumed to be
the entitled sony marvel sequel
which the studio was slotted for an
october 2020 release but that is no
longer set in stone
due to the departure of venom director
ruben fleischer who has had his hands
full with the long-awaited sequel to his
2009 classic zombieland but the second
go round for the lethal protector is
still in active development
with original scribe kelly marcel
already drafting a screenplay
and hardy's set to return along with
co-star michelle williams plot details
are sketchy but one thing is certain
just as cassidy promised in that stinger
when i get out of here
and i will
there's gonna be carnage variety
confirmed in january 2019 that
harrelson's murderer symbiote will be
venom two's main villain
it's a little tough to believe that at
this point spider-man has a rich
cinematic history spanning almost 20
years and nearly a dozen feature films
yet here we are for all the box office
bugs rigged in by some raimi's trilogy
the amazing spider-man reboot series and
the mcu iteration ably portrayed by tom
holland however none of those films were
able to do what sony pictures animation
spider-man into the spider-verse did
score an academy award 2018's best
animated feature winner is considered by
some to be among the best if not the
best
superhero films ever made with its
supremely innovative animation style
and focus on its eclectic cast of
alternate universe spider people
it's so singular a cinematic achievement
that it seems like its success would be
impossible to duplicate
but darned if sony isn't going to try
the spider verse sequel will center on
the burgeoning romantic relationship
between miles morales and gwen stacy aka
ghost spider
and according to co-director rodney
rothman will take place two years after
the events of the first film
additional plot details are still a
mystery but sony pictures amy pascal has
let slip that the sequel will feature
even more female versions
of spidey besides gwen stacy and penny
parker in fact it was served to set up a
spin-off film focused entirely on these
characters
in the form of a similarly animated film
that will introduce classic spider woman
jessica drew along with cindy moon
also known as silk disney's acquisition
of fox gave the house of mouse a 60
stake in hulu and even before the deal
closed the streamer was looking to
expand its marvel offerings beyond its
hit original series runaways
the first set of announced new projects
however came as a bit of a surprise
four adult animated series centered on
some of the quirkier characters in
marvel law
which will of course cross over for a
team-up special all co-produced by tv
evp
jeff loeb each series features creative
talent just as eclectic as the
characters themselves
get ready for the tiger and dazzler show
produced by chelsea handler hit monkey
courtesy of blades of glory writing team
josh gordon
and will speck modok which will be
written and produced by patton oswalt
and
wait for it what do you let it leaky
like that for
gross
that's right kevin smith will be homing
howard the duck obviously each series
looks to be aiming for its own distinct
comedic vibe but
low will be tasked with bringing them
all together for the offenders a one-off
special in which all of these weird
characters will team up to tackle a
common enemy which threatens the world
marvel's first foray into animated
comedy looks interesting to say the
least and finally we'll hopefully get a
version of howard the duck to once and
for all purge the memory of that
terrible
terrible 1986 film now you
and babyface are gonna beat it right mr
zits
before i get really mad
well the sequel to the billion dollar
plus grossing captain marvel seems like
a foregone conclusion
it has also yet to be confirmed
according to leaker extraordinaire
wardell the wheels are turning
starbury larson is reported to have
signed a seven picture deal with marvel
and this sure seems unlikely that the
studio's brass would be content to
simply have carol danvers pop up in
other characters movies after her first
solo vehicle stellar box office
performance
interestingly wardell isn't the only
leaker to have claimed inside knowledge
about captain marvel 2
a redditor posting under the name the
marvel scoop master asserted that the
sequel will take place during avengers
end games five year time jump and we'll
see carol danvers tangle with the
interdimensional cyborg michael korvac a
character with a history in the comics
stretching back to 1975 who had dealings
with the likes of the grandmaster and
doctor strange the redditor claims that
danvers will investigate a cree's secret
weapon
that turns out to be kovac and that the
two will initially bond over having both
been in willing cree experiments
but then kovac will betray danvers and
the two will end up doing battle in the
film's climax
of course this is merely an
unsubstantiated rumor so be sure to take
it with a grain of salt
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one